hop ils sont actuellement plus de 200
milles en lorraine hommes femmes enfants
venus de 32 pays d'europe d'afrique et
d'asie
ils cherchent en france le salaire qui
leur permettra de vivre mieux
la promotion sociale qui les élève rat
un avenir meilleur pour leurs enfants
il débarque pour la plupart un jour sur
le cas du dard mon rôle consistait à les
accueillir un bar et ensuite s'ils sont
ses papiers en règle tu es tu le sens
voilà l'emploi qu'ils veulent aller et
s'ils n'ont pas ses papiers
j'ai les jambes rocher
initialement elle sait ça vous fait
partie du comité lyautey wii qui a des
antennes un peu dans toute la france
intet la volt au lion ça quel est le
l'attitude des gens que vous ramassez en
quelque sorte sur le quai de la gare est
ce que c'est difficile de les aborder
ça dépend pour les espagnols des
postures et ce n'est pas tellement
difficile mais publie sa lave c'est plus
difficile car il se méfie beaucoup alors
quand je commence à lui poser des
questions de foi ils ne prennent pour
quelqu'un de la police ne sait pas il se
juge sur le centre d'accueil des
migrants
ici malgré elle je viens de recevoir à
l'étranger en portugais qui arrive
il n'a pas de prix il n'a pas de
passeport il n'a pas de travail n'ont
pas d'argent non plus alors je vous
l'envoie parce que maman je suis pas
quoi faire oui vous allez relever boulou
et parce qu'il a rien sous louer
d'accord au revoir merci
entre le village dante ils viennent pour
la plupart et la ville écrasante qui les
reçoit il n'ya pas de commune mesure
c'est dans la rue que commence la longue
recherche un logement du travail et sur
tout un contact humain rassurant avec
des compatriotes d'abord qu'ils
comprendront son langage et son
dépaysement avec aussi des hommes au
grand coeur qui consacrent leur vie à
les aider dans les différentes démarches
[Musique]
et
ces hommes il s'appelle demain gel
religieux sans sultane ou poly
syndicalistes de longwy qui l'ont
surnommé l'avocat
[Musique]
il
via notre rôle ici en tant que l'union
locale des syndicats c'est de défendre
l'ensemble des travailleurs et
particulièrement ces deux grandes
parties d'immigrés qui viennent ici
travailler dans notre bassin et qui sont
souvent disons où les patrons ne
respecte pas les conventions collectives
les salaires ainsi que le droit du
travail
alors vous avez une beaucoup d'entre
beaucoup de travailleurs qui travaillent
dans les entreprises il ya nice ils nous
montrent leur but alpes et il nous
demande si ces bouteilles sont juste ou
pas juste alors nous pensons attend que
les ouvriers immigrés ils ne sont pas
dans leur classification
ils viennent avec des contrats de
travail sous l'étiquette ouvriers
qualifiés maçon ou ferrailleurs et ses
terrains et quand on regarde leur
bulletin de paye et bien ils sont payés
comme des ouvriers spécialisés et ils
sont tous des prix et j'ai d'étape très
souvent ou les on le remet sur leurs
contacts rail 4 france 5 de la route ou
4 fois 50 de l'heure et ils sont payés
87 ou 3,50 outre trois cas francs 40 de
leurs du fait qu'ils ne sont pas
organisés dans des petites entreprises
puisque ils subissent la répression de
la part des patrons alors nous avons un
recours au conseil des prud'hommes
donc pour vous les dossiers des
immigrants sont plus difficiles à
plaider et que ceux d'un ouvrier qui est
né dans la région où il est beaucoup
plus difficile à faire de l'angel vos
repères vous représentez l'échelon
central de l'ami c'est-à-dire de
l'association des migrants qui a son
siège à metz vous recevez beaucoup de
monde évidemment quelles sont les
questions principales que vous abordez
avec les migrants eh bien écoutez comme
vous venez de dire vous trouvez ici au
bureau d'intervention de notre
association d'accueil des migrants
les quatre nous avons à élucider ce sont
enfin ce sont des problèmes d'accueil
d'abord les difficultés se situent
surtout au niveau de l'hébergement c'est
peut-être la question la plus difficile
mais aussi beaucoup des problèmes de
régularisation de situation pour des
ouvriers étrangers arrivés en moselle
sans contrat de travail
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
votre rôle est plus important dans le
domaine purement matérielle des papiers
de l'emploi de l'accueil etc ou dans le
domaine psychologique
alors là j'ai pas de mal à vous répondre
il est évident que c'est surtout peut
être au niveau psychologique
encore que les deux soient intimement
liés mais nous voulons justement non pas
doublés d administration qui l ont des
services prévus pour agir efficacement
mais ce que nous voulons faire nous
c'est c'est le lien si vous voulez nous
voulons donner une qualité à laquelle
ils vont souvent se faire exploiter
principalement par leurs compatriotes
derrière les volets clos des vieilles
façades des chambres et insalubres louer
à prix d'or par des tenanciers sans
scrupules abrite leur désarroi leur
nostalgie leurs espoirs
chaque immigrant représenta cas précis
un problème humain qu'il faut étudier
patiemment seuls des organismes privés
inspiré par un simple souci de
solidarité peuvent établir le contact
humain direct à longwy c'est le rôle que
ces deniers l'union syndicale génériques
pour la grande majorité de ces pagnes
ans que nous venons ici trouver là notre
pays ne naît pas de travail nous
trouvons trop de difficultés dans
beaucoup de matière ils nous confient
des travaux les plots mobile et moi
faget monsieur félix quel est l'effectif
de d'ouvriers originaires de l'afrique
du nord dans cette région on compte
environ 2500 algérien à peu près deux à
trois cents autres auteurs pro sortis
sans l'afrique du nord quels sont pour
eux les problèmes les plus difficiles
les problèmes les plus difficiles sont
les problèmes de l'immigré en général
mais je pense que ce qui les marque le
plus c'est le fait des conditions de
travail pénibles surtout avec le climat
d'ici beaucoup tombent malades
avec tout ce que cela entraîne comme
conséquences pour leurs familles restées
en afrique du nord qui n'ont plus haut
aucune subsides dans ce cas là le fait
aussi d'être d'être seul et de subir le
racisme volontaire ou involontaire dé la
part des patrons et aussi de la part des
gens pour la plupart des gens encore
même s'ils le disent pas ouvertement
c'est encore j'ai rien
or africain c'est le [ __ ] encore où
le [ __ ] et je pense que le logement
doit alors prendre une assez grande part
de ce petit salaire ben je crois que
hilary va s'arranger à plusieurs
d'après ce que je sais la plupart se
logent à bon marché quand même entre
5000 et 10000 par mois pour une petite
pièce
actuellement la situation est plutôt
mauvaise que ce qu'elle était il ya dix
ans je crois qu'elle s'améliorerait de
s'améliorer vous représentez vous
monsieur l'italie et l'italie se trouve
dans le cadre du marché commun donc il
ya je pense des accords particuliers
avec ce pays et il y a des accords
particuliers un rapport publié lé et si
on peut dire là pour votre migration
puisque il ya des règlements même
nouveaux qui sont intervenus qui donnant
certaines droits que les autres
non pas jeter migration ou pas et puis
il faut dire que vous avez des syndicats
qui sont extrêmement bien organisés en
italie ce qui n'est pas le cas pour les
portugais ou les espagnols par exemple
il ya eu un accord entre la cgt
italienne et la société française depuis
1958 dans le but de défendre les
intérêts des travailleurs italiens en
france et cet accord la sagec la cgt
italienne ils ont formé des bourreaux
dans toute la france et si on enlevait
lourd régional le vos enfants lorsqu'ils
grandissent vous les envoyer à l'école
est ce qu'il ya des problèmes de ce côté
là tant qu'ils sont petits noms qui vont
à l'école primaire mais dès qu'ils ont
fini l'école primaire les enfants d
immigrés n'ont pas droit aux bourses
d'études c'est un peu injuste puisque on
estime que les ballons et on sait
souffrir et eux ils n'auraient pas dû
subir certaines conséquences alors que
faites vous des enfants ce qu'ils
grandissent pour les garçons il n'y a
pas de problème s'ils n'arrivent pas à
étudier la piste et ils y trouvent du
travail facilement mais les fils étaient
difficiles et cela malgré le règlement
16-12 de la communauté économique
européenne qui prévoir
il ne doit pas y avoir de discrimination
pour l'emploi les filles elles ne sont
pas embauchés du fait qu'ils sont
italiennes difficilement elle l'appelle
embauches mais quand on voit que c'est
l'italienne même avec un certificat
meurent kcap il dijon peut pas vous
embaucher parce que le mien pour les
portugais monsieur la difficulté
commence sur le territoire portugais lui
même
effectivement les difficultés commencent
bien avant le départ puisque ce sont des
gens qui n'ont rien aussi dira mais
comme sentent comme des gens honnêtes
ils empruntent de l'argent nécessaire
pour payer le passeur qui les amènera en
france donc ils s'endettent ils
s'endettent et c'est somme qu'il demande
qu'ils empruntent varient entre 100 et
120 mille francs anciens
il y aura ensuite à notre problème c'est
la même dépense pour est familier c'est
la même dépense pour la famille parce
qu'il faut qu'il laisse un peu d'argent
à la famille et c'est ces gens viennent
en france endettée souffrent dans leur
chair puisqu'il assure terre natale
leurs familles leurs formes et leurs
enfants et bientôt péril de leur vie en
péril de leur vie et clandestinement
clandestinement
c'est à dire qu'il s'agit de passer de
frontières la frontière patrick hesse la
frontière espagnole un dire espagnols
mais ensuite la frontière française la
frontière française de la question
français se sentent déjà en sécurité
je suis originaire du sénégal et pourra
sénégalais qui débarque à metz en pleine
lorraine et en plein hiver également
quels sont les problèmes
enfin le problème ne reste alors moins
pardonné étant donné mon problème
particulier res de l'embauché d'autres
de talent que les jeunes aient enfin
certes que le climat je ne suis pas
passé assez mal mais n'a au moins je
crois que j'aime me ferez oui votre
problème principal c'est la joie parce
que de toute façon je ne pense pas
pouvoir vivre
étant donné le climat pouvoir vivre
comme bear combien payez-vous à l'hôtel
actuellement à l'hôtel je paie 10 10
francs par nuit c'est à dire 300 francs
par mois race enfant va décoller votre
salaire à mon salaire mardi enfin j'ai
82 oui il tourne autour de 600 700
francs par mois réalisant 800 à 900 par
mois et est ce que vous avez des charges
familiales au sénégal puis enfin j'ai
des charges familiales de temps
reconnaît je suis
je suis folle udc pour enfin pouvoir
donner un petit enfin un petit peu
d'argent afin que je puisse faire vivre
certaines personnes qui m'a parle de
quoi
sur an tandis la région de longwy est
une des grandes régions d'immigration de
la lorraine
quel est le pourcentage de la population
dans le bassin de longwy 12% de la
population qui représente 32
nationalités
39e quel effectif se présentent-ils ben
ali a pris en quatorze mille
travailleurs immigrés de quelle
nationalité italienne nigérienne
portugaises espagnoles mais disons que
la grosse partie ce sont des italiens
soutiennent un effectif un peu près 7000
italiens 2000 algériens et des gens que
le reste est partagé entre portugais
espagnols et polonais sur le plan social
donc vous vous préoccupez à l'échelon
syndicale il y a des problèmes qui sont
graves qu'elle est le plus grave
le problème de sur le plan social le
plus grave c'est d'un côté la
discrimination qui portait en direction
des travailleurs émigrés et ensuite
notamment l'oeuvre sociale en elle-même
vous avez diverses choses les
allocations familiales
martin en particulier est naturellement
tout ce qui représente le social dans
son ensemble alors le social c'est à
dire les professions et le logement
alors que pouvez-vous faire bien de ce
côté là nous avons
dans le cadre des grandes entreprises
puisque vous savez que les émigrés dans
le bassin 110 en grosse majorité dans
les entreprises de la sidérurgie des
mines et du bâtiment mais dans les
grandes entreprises avec l'aide des
organisations syndicales et les comités
d'entreprise nous avons fait beaucoup de
choses par rapport à l'habitat et par
rapport naturellement à l'amélioration
des cantines
nous avons réussi en gros dans ces
entreprises à faire disparaître maximum
les baraquements
est ce que vous estimez que vous êtes
arrivé déjà des résultats par rapport
aux portugais aux espagnols si oui à
l'ensemble de l'immigration et à
l'ensemble de régulation naturellement
par rapport aux italiens ou lundi on a
treize bruit dossier tous les ans et son
art est des privilégiés
mais par rapport aux portugaises
espagnoles nous avons ensemble nous
avons semble bien malgré toutes les
difficultés qu'on peut rencontrer
embauché loger l'immigrant veut parfois
poursuivre son intégration dans notre
société
il veut connaître notre langue la parler
l'écrire à metz l'association pour
l'accueil des immigrants a créé des
cours du soir ou des moniteurs bénévoles
après nos travailleurs étrangers
particulièrement les algériens les
rudiments de français qui vont leur
permettre de se sentir plus proches de
leurs compagnons d'ateliers ils tous les
jours
le soleil
on
[Musique]
non c'est une dire que comme celle de
ses proches
[Musique]
c'est moi j'ai juste encore là regardez
ce que faisaient les crimes visés mots
après mon ennemi des noms
oui alors oui peu à peu
l'aspect familial du problème des
immigrants devient essentiel il faut
songer aux enfants qui peut-être ne
retourneront pas dans le pays d'origine
pour eux il n'y a pas de grandes
difficultés l'école primaire les
accueille à l'égal des petits lorrain
des difficultés commenceront plus tard
avec l'enseignement secondaire ou
techniques mais ceci est une autre
histoire
dans l'immédiat l'intégration de la
femme pose les problèmes les plus
délicats bonsecours notre jury à
quelques jours pour aller va tomber
et j'ai demandé quand est ce qu'ils
sortiraient de la maternité les
prématurés alors dans un mois le vivat
rentrée la maison alors avec toi il
faudrait qu'on puisse ensemble établir
ton budget dans le mois qui va venir
pour voir comment tu vas prévoir pour
acheter tout ce qu'il faudra pour le
mais est-ce que financièrement
actuellement est-ce que vous avez assez
d'argent ou un peu d'argent de côté ou
pas du tout j'en ai perdu ont coûté un
petit peu mou et un petit peu c'est ça
veut dire pour toi acheter tu peux
acheter un en ligne youtube
rassemblement chat biberon moi je peux
acheter peu de vêtements aussi des boues
vent un peu bêtement mais bon bon alors
ce qu'il faudrait c'est colt mohamed il
aura sa paye quand il va toucher ça paye
il faudra avec lui qu'on voit ensemble
sur sa paye qu'est-ce qu'on peut retirer
pour acheter soit quelques vêtements
soit à biberon ou une bassine quand tu
crois que tu laves les poupées qu'on
prévoir quand il aura trouvé le plus
convaincant tu comprends maintenant
bon alors tu là depuis quatre mois
maintenant 4 4 mais aussi à l'art est ce
que tu pourrais est ce que maintenant
c'est toi qui va faire les courses
socialement amen
défoncez moi des fois un simple coucou
et y va tout seul
oui oui je vous dis là tout seul les
galeries tu vas nous tous seuls 2 cv et
qu'est-ce que tu arrives à acheter et à
payer mais j'arrive acheté un billet et
pourquoi diable comment tu as fait le
passage en alerte en état du début quand
on arrive aux nouvelles galeries de ne
pas acheter
et puis maintenant tu arrives à acheter
qu'est ce qui t'a aidé hdc mauric
montrer comment comment il fallait
cachette quoi je sais plus comment
j'achète comment j'ai payé tout il faut
où il faut leur part il fallait payer où
ils font passer pour payer oui passer
pour pays d'avant d'abord en fait la
commission des problèmes religieuse
apparaissent dans la vie quotidienne le
musulman ne mange pas la viande des
chrétiens les roumis l'animal doit être
égorgé selon le rite prescrit par
mahomet
[Musique]
je
l'itv les moutons pas comme les arts d
un truc tu pas quand et comment étaient
parfois chez nous avons été avec le
couteau il faut faire d'abord sans
prière et prie le dieu il est il est
complet les gorges
oui là il égaré dans les salles oui la
nostalgie au goût amer atteint parfois
les exilés dans leur solitude entre les
pays ensoleillés d'où viennent
généralement ces hommes et ces femmes et
nos régions d'europe le soleil n'est
qu'à trop rare privilège
il y à des distances qu'on évalue pas en
kilomètres la grisaille d'un ciel
lorrain souvent chargés de fumée incline
au spleen le soir dans les bistrots
enfumé perdu dans un monde qui n'ont pas
encore assimilé les immigrants retrouve
dans les machines à musique les airs qui
les rapproche d'un instant du pays
pour ceux des immigrants qui auront
choisi de s'établir en france
l'adaptation à la nouvelle patrie sera
parfois difficile mais bien des italiens
bien des polonais ils sont arrivés à la
deuxième ou troisième génération la
différence les plus apparentes que dans
la coloration des cheveux le contour
d'un visage pour les fils ou petit fils
d'immigrant c'est dans le pays d'origine
qui pourrait y avoir un jour un
véritable déracinement
[Musique]